I am number one on YouTube because my
fans are the most loyal people in the
world I tell them to do something they
do it you know hey guys go thumb up this
video million thumbs comes with a lot of
power though because power to be like
hey guys go jump off a bridge you know
you'd see you'd see a lot of bridges
with dead bodies under them we're going
to crown the web star of the year I can
do the Miley spoof everybody's already
seen we can't want pink it's a hundred
million views how about the new weekend
spoof I can't find my vase isn't ready
yet hello puppies I member day and
you're watching the viral video pound
ruff ruff
so I started a channel that's one scared
baby and every week I try to scare Lucy
get her face no that's one scary baby
it's really hard for people to take you
seriously when 700 million people have
seen you dance like an idiot on the
internet politicians used it as a way to
sum up everything that was wrong with
our country I'm a film director I'd
worked with what I had
so my cat mr. blankets became my muse
this is the moment we've all been
waiting for
we're on our way should a webcam right
now
oh my shining stars you're here Wow all
of you in one room is the big shows a
lot of pressure who will get their very
own TV show oh my god is that baby
driving
that's real little viral I got a 20 foot
let's do this faster it's the
entertainment of tomorrow experiment is
happening it's not
six seconds I'm not wearing any
underwear Korsak it's time to rock it
doesn't even matter
nothing has substance Al Hirt uh no it's
a medium I get it I get it I get it
bow bow bow I talked to a person who's
younger than 40 he's like the little
gives me a nice key
turned out they were talking about the
Internet